vous connaissez la marque de gaming
Razer Razer Razer Razer vous connaissez
les claviers les souris ça fait de la
couleur tous les côtés c'est très bien
et surtout Razer a beaucoup de
technologie et réserve invité
aujourd'hui à Londres pour venir
découvrir leur nouveau clavier alors
pour l'instant je sais pas grand chose
si ce n'est que ça va être un nouveau
clavier orienté gaming peut-être
productivité allez savoir pour les
créateurs ça peut m'intéresser donc
aujourd'hui une vidéo qui est réserve en
partenariat avec Razer ici à Londres je
pense que ça va être cool on va se
marrer on va découvrir une technologie
qui va être probablement super
intéressant pour différents univers
est-ce que vous êtes prêts allez on y va
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il prodigue vient nous présenter Razer
ici c'est le Black Widow V4 pro il est
juste là regardez alors il y en a plein
de tous les côtés nous ont fait un
événement on est juste en dessous du
Razor Store à Londres et donc vous avez
des claviers de tous les côtés
s'ajoutent tous les côtés alors je vous
expliquais je vous présentais ce produit
qui est intéressant qui est vraiment là
pour le gaming mais en fait ce qui est
très cool c'est qu'il est là pour le
gaming mais qu'il est pas là uniquement
pour le gaming donc si vous intéressez
au gaming mais pas ko gaming que vous
voulez un produit orienté gaming mais
que vous êtes également créateur et bien
c'est intéressant regardez ce mot sur
votre clavier vous avez ici une petite
molette et en fait ces petites molette
elle vous servira quelque chose
différentes actions par exemple ici dans
votre logiciel vous venez par exemple
passer à ce que vous voulez faire je
vous montre donc là vous venez activer
je vais avoir la lumière verte je vais
avoir le rouge et ses différents modes
donc ça c'est la lumière du clavier donc
pour venir activer hop là j'appuie
jusqu'à avoir le verre donc là j'ai le
vert ça me l'affiche vous voyez ça me
change les modes lorsque j'appuie dessus
en fait et ça correspond à ce que je
vais retrouver ici donc ça c'est un
espèce de petit raccourci qui est quand
même vachement cool là par exemple
Windows zoom je viens le tourner et je
suis sur cette fonction là là hop le
bleu c'est switching entre différentes
applications donc là vous voyez je vais
pouvoir switcher entre mes différentes
apps moi je celle là et là je peux les
activer le désactiver donc il y en a que
je peux venir activer je peux venir
customiser je peux venir en créer aussi
ça c'est vachement cool là je peux venir
choisir changer la couleur faire une
couleur custom si je veux je peux venir
l'activer le désactiver je peux venir en
créer très facilement j'ai qu'à cliquer
custom donc là je lui donne le nom que
je veux je mets la couleur que je veux
je peux aller dessus directement et
ensuite là je vais avoir mes différentes
fonctions que je vais venir choisir donc
ça je trouve ça assez marrant en fait
parce que on peut vraiment venir
customiser très facilement directement
sur la replacement fou je sa poubelle et
vous avez pas moins de 8 touches macro
dédiés alors vous en avez une deux trois
quatre cinq six sept huit vous avez
trois qui sont planqués sur le côté et
pareil de la même manière si par exemple
je veux venir customiser cette touche
qui se trouve ici je vais tout avoir
directement la avec différentes
fonctions on va mettre c'est pas mal
d'avoir sur le clavier ici directement
c'est 5 touches 5 raccourcis je pourrais
revenir personnaliser alors ce qui est
très cool en plus c'est que ça va
dépendre si je vais être sur l'univers
du gaming par exemple et bien je peux
donner différentes actions là ça peut
être monté le volume baisser le volume
et compagnie mais lorsque je suis
créatif par exemple je peux lié avec
Photoshop avec Photoshop c'est-à-dire
ben tiens je reviens en arrière bah non
je comptais je vais mettre ça je peux
venir dupliquer bref je peux
complètement de la personnaliser sans
oublier mes trois fonctions ici Java ça
c'est vachement cool et en plus de ça
ils sont venus rajouter cette petite
molette là que je vais pouvoir utiliser
également alors en gaming si on le
souhaite mais je peux utiliser notamment
pour moi je pense en tant que de créatif
sur Photoshop et là j'ai différentes
touches qui sont marquées play pose
avant arrière couper le son mais que je
peux complètement venir assigner ici
directement la façon dont je le souhaite
donc ça c'est vachement cool en terme de
personnalisation on peut vraiment venir
faire ce qu'on veut et une fois de plus
là où l'idée de ce clavier est très
maligne et ça ça me plaît bien
qui nous ont mis qui est vachement bien
c'est cette petite partie là qui va être
bien pour avoir l'amorti effectivement
j'ai pas passé des heures dessus je vous
le cache pas mais il y a effectivement
toute une zone de confort un peu
coussinet pour venir l'utiliser comme ça
ça c'est quand même vachement bien fichu
et le repose poignet ici étant 6000 cuir
voilà regardez vous voyez on a ce côté
un petit peu faux cuir mais qui malgré
tout n'est pas du cuir donc ça c'est
quand même vachement cool le truc que je
trouve vachement bien c'est que on a un
accès très rapide au bouton alors
ceux-là sont un petit peu planqué
derrière donc faut vraiment venir
pousser la main et venir au-dessus pour
venir les choper on vient au-dessus on
redescend là et là on trouve ces boutons
et la molette alors après ce que j'aime
bien c'est cette sensation un peu de
difficulté à venir le pousser parce que
c'est pas vrai mais c'est pas un truc
qui va être trop facile qui va être trop
bouger donc on vient vraiment
complètement le sentir c'est un peu de
résistance que je trouve vachement bien
pareil ici on a un peu de résistance et
sous le doigt on sent vraiment bien le
clip et je trouve ça malin et ça c'est
très très cool
[Musique]
bien on peut venir le mettre sur tout ce
qu'on veut ici on nous met sur du
nanolea vous pouvez le faire alors il y
a tous l'écosystème Razer pour avoir une
ambiance totalement personnalisée bien
évidemment vous faites tout ici dans
votre chrome un studio et ce qui est
bien c'est que vous pouvez enlever la
partie du bas de votre clavier ça vaut
le coup alors tout le reste fonctionne
vous le remettez au bien venir le
connecter par le dessous et là il vient
se reconnecter il vient se remettre
directement donc ça vous voyez c'est
simple c'est pratique c'est joli et une
fois de plus il y a plus toute cette
notion sur d'écosystème connecté qu'on
va retrouver avec Raizer et qui est
juste super sympa si vous aimez ça voilà
il faut aimer une fois de plus et moi je
trouve ça super efficace ce qui est cool
chez Resort c'est que vous avez
possibilité de vendre deux options au
niveau des touches soit sentir
réellement clique soit pas le sentir ça
c'est à vous de voir vous choisissez ce
que vous aimez la configuration qui vous
plaira bien évidemment ici vous avez
tout un boîtier qui est fait en aliage
d'aluminium et toi qui est complètement
dingué nous annonce jusqu'à 100 millions
de frappes 100 millions de frappes au
niveau de votre clavier autant vous dire
que là vous êtes peinard vous y allez
vous pouvez taper vous pouvez jouer
pendant des heures vous pouvez faire des
tonnes de trucs je suis en train de
m'imaginer en train de faire la dactylo
sont absolument ridicule vous pouvez
jouer pendant des heures vous pouvez
faire de l'édition du travail du
contrôle tout ce que vous voulez 100
millions de frappes je trouve ça
absolument dingue
ce qui fait l'ADN de Razer c'est bien
évidemment toutes celles RGB ça on le
sait mais c'est la personnalisation
c'est le fait de pouvoir aller
extrêmement loin de faire ce qu'on veut
et ce qui est génial c'est clair vous
avez jusqu'à 100 modes pour venir
totalement personnaliser votre
expérience avec votre clavier donc ça je
compte sur une fois de plus très cool
parce que ça va dépendre de l'ambiance
qu'on va vouloir et ce qui est très
intéressant une fois de plus alors il
faut aimer une fois de plus les claviers
avec des LED RGB il faut aimer l'esprit
de Razer mais si vous êtes gamer si vous
aimez la marque et si vous voulez aller
sur ce nouveau clavier une fois de plus
qu'il faut voir est-ce qu'il faut
comprendre au-delà de ce clavier mais de
l'ensemble de produits de l'écosystème
qu'on peut venir trouver chez Razer
c'est l'idée de la personnalisation et
de l'immersion vous avez jusqu'à 100
modes différents pour venir totalement
personnaliser l'expérience et si vous
ouvrez l'écosystème avec d'autres je
vous dis compatible avec du Philips Hue
avec du nanoleaf et bien d'autres encore
et bien vous allez emmener l'expérience
beaucoup plus loin et je trouve ça super
intéressant on peut se faire des super
setup on peut venir tout personnaliser
et si en plus vous êtes gamer si vous
êtes streamer et si vous voulez avoir un
ensemble encore plus cohérent plus beau
plus joli avec un setup beaucoup plus
grand vous avez énormément de
possibilités ici donc c'est vraiment ce
qui me plaît moi ce que je trouve
intéressant avec cette marque c'est
toute cette notion d'écosystème cette
notion de personnalisation le fait de
pouvoir aller très loin au niveau du
gaming mais moi ce qui me touche encore
plus aujourd'hui c'est que on se parle
pas que de gaming on se parle de
productivité on se parle de Photoshop on
se parle de venir m'a fait ses touches
donc ce clavier il est beau il est
pratique mais une fois de plus c'est un
vrai outil productivité pour des
personnes qui ont un usage un peu mixte
une casquette gaming qui aime se faire
plaisir avec cet écosystème et cet
univers chez Razer mais qui veulent
également en outre une productivité où
on peut aller vraiment très loin et ça
une fois de plus on va super chouette et
si vous venez regarder par ici derrière
vous avez deux ports usbc vous avez de
l'usba et si vous voulez lui donner un
peu plus d'angle vous pouvez venir lever
cette petite partie là pour venir lever
davantage votre clavier d'un côté mais
également de l'autre côté ce qui fait
que ça va donner légèrement plus d'angle
votre post poignée quant à lui il vient
se connecter vous le voyez là vous avez
cette petite connectique qui est ici que
vous venez poser en dessous et lorsqu'il
se reconnecte il vient se rallumer très
simplement on peut venir choisir sa
position soit vous le surélevé soit vous
le Suez relevez pas à vous de voir d'un
côté et de l'autre et une fois de plus
vous avez votre possibilité de venir
brancher deux câbles USB c ça c'est
plutôt pas mal
et c'est un clavier qu'on a trouvé au
tarif de
269,99 €. alors je parle bien ici de
l'euro les tarifs en livre puisqu'on est
à Londres mais on a les tarifs en euros
ça c'est plutôt chouette et plutôt
pratique voilà je sais pas comment vous
le trouvez est-ce que ça vous intéresse
est-ce que vous êtes déjà client Razer
est-ce que vous pourriez le devenir
qu'est-ce que vous pensez de ce clavier
le Black Widow V4 pro on se parle bien
ici la version V4 si vous n'êtes pas
gamer est-ce que ça pourrait vous
intéresser est-ce que vous pourriez
aller sur un clavier comme ça est-ce que
vous aimez le côté RGB le côté
personnalisation le côté décoration
c'est pas vrai mais le côté d'abord un
peu cette atmosphère cet univers gaming
sans forcément être un hardcore gamer ou
même que joueur gamer sans forcément
aimer beaucoup jouer moi je suis pas un
très grand gamer j'aime bien de temps en
temps viens me faire une petite partie
de m'amuser why not mais j'ai pas trop
mon truc mais pour autant j'aime
beaucoup la marque j'aime beaucoup
l'ensemble des produits écosystèmes
qu'ils ont développé je serai malin
parce qu'on ne fait plus s'adresse au
gamer ils ont compris qu'il y a un pont
il le savent entre le gamer et le
streamer donc on a vachement de produits
de streaming il y a vachement de
solutions qui sont super intéressantes
qu'on voit d'ailleurs ici dans le rise
of stars parce qu'on n'a pas de Razer
store nous à Paris il y en a un ici à
qui est super chouette je pense que
c'est plus du 360 degrés vous avez
différentes catégories de produits on va
vraiment avoir le hardcore gamer qui
fait que jouer qui achète qui joue qui
va un produit Razer qui lui plaît bien
why not on a également le streamer gamer
qui Stream qui va sur les réseaux qui
partagent son jeu et on a des outils
effectivement de streaming et puis RAZOR
vient draguer une fois de plus c'est
créateur de contenu qui vont venir en
plus faire leur miniature Photoshop qui
va me dire la création qui viennent
travailler donc vous voyez on a un
ensemble de produits un peu tout en un
écosystème qui se développe de plus en
plus avec des produits tous les côtés
sont 5 fois plus très malins et ce
clavier le Black Widow V4 Pro vient
totalement s'imbriquer ici on est à mon
avis dans cet usage qui est un peu mixte
gamer streamer créateur de contenu c'est
un peu là qui vient se positionner donc
moi je trouve ça m'arrange comme ça bien
d'ailleurs dites-moi vous ce que vous en
pensez dans les commentaires est-ce que
ça pourrait vous tenter qu'est-ce que
vous pensez de Razer est-ce que ça vous
plaît ça vous plaît pas ça vous parle ça
vous parle pas est-ce que c'est une
marque sur laquelle vous êtes déjà allé
est-ce que vous avez déjà acheté des
produits dizer et est-ce que ce Black
Widow V4 pro pourrait vous tenter dites
le moi dans les commentaires et puis
nous on se retrouve très bientôt pour
continuer à parler tech peut-être de
Razer allez savoir allez je vous
embrasse prenez soin de vous et à très
bientôt Ciao
[Musique]